j'ai des cauchemars pierre ah bah oui ça
vous arrive souvent oui oui ça va vous
arriver ce soir merde à faire une
interview cauchemar
[Musique]
pierre vous ressembler à quoi dans vos
cauchemars je suis à l'école et le prof
me dis c'est pas parce que vous êtes
célèbre qu'il faut pas faire votre voix
et je me réveille en sueur
sans avoir fait évidemment c'est qui
votre femme dans vos cauchemars ma mère
alors freud
horizon la république dans vos
cauchemars ce qui à bam moi oui
franchement je serais pas quoi [ __ ] de
la france vous acceptez quel film dans
vos cauchemars en faire un film de cul
parce que je
vois là on vous fait quoi comme critique
dans vos cauchemars ok
maintenant c'est que je me remette le
chemin
vous vivez au caire dans vos cauchemars
août en dix endroits d'un cauchemar une
île déserte où un petit village enfin là
où il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde j'ai
pas de barbe la nuit et tout ça m'arrête
je suis pas que ça
vous écoutez quoi comme musique dans le
cauchemar du rap ah ouais mais pas
seulement
enfin du rap et de la house
va seulement dans mes cauchemars dans
les banlieues où je veux aussi quoi
vous avez peur de quoi dans vos
cauchemars pierre
g j'ai peur qu'on me pardonne pas oui et
mes erreurs ouais vous mourrez
commandant vos cauchemars un jour j'ai
rêvé que je mourrais comment as tu un
nom de noyer dit soutenir une voiture et
je les loyers
mais revêt la voiture était dans un lac
un estomac n'est pas en train de
conduire et
on découvre quoi sur vous dans vos
cauchemars je suis un mauvais coup
vous faites attaquer parquet l'animal
dans vos cauchemars
or je suis fatigué un jour par une loi
non c'est terrible
vous faites chargé par une oie s'est
passé c'est mauvais je sais j'en ai la
campagne non mais c'est vrai en même
temps les oies c'est un avantage c'est
que c'est le meilleur chien de garde loi
oui et puis on peut la bouffe et à
prêcher le groupe nous fait trop penser
que cette interview n'est qu'un
cauchemar qui va bientôt s'arrêter
pierre tuvéri ans est un rêve ça vient
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous je m'étais 1
pouces bleus